the theory of evolution tells us that
space and time are not fundamental
they're more like a headset a virtual
reality headset that lets us play the
game of life
[Music]
so how does one go about solving the
hard problem of consciousness
well so
most of my good friends and colleagues
who are studying the hard problem of
Consciousness are physicalists they
assume that space and time are
fundamental and that objects inside
space and time like the um the
elementary particles of the standard
model of physics the the the bosons
leptons and quarks for example are
fundamental parts of reality and then
any objects that are made out of them
are part of reality as well so protons
neutrons and neurons and brains so
that's they start with space-time and
physical objects in space-time as the
fundamental reality and assume that life
and Consciousness are late comers
uh
that the Universe began in the Big Bang
there was no life there was no
consciousness and it took millions
billions of years for life to emerge and
then who knows how much longer after
that for Consciousness to emerge that's
that's the standard story and so for
them the question is how do physical
systems such as brains or maybe
artificial intelligences give rise to
consciousness
and my attitude is that that whole
framework
um
is missing the results of our best
scientific theories namely evolution of
a natural selection on the one hand and
also Quantum field Theory and Einstein's
theory of gravity both of which tell us
that space-time is doomed
the space-time has been assumed to be
fundamental for centuries of space and
time and then space time more recently
has been assumed to be fundamental and
it's been a wonderful framework but our
best theories tell us it's over that
that framework is is not fundamental and
we need to find some new mathematically
precise
um more fundamental ideas outside of
space-time so space time is doomed
that's that's what physicists like
David Gross are saying about space-time
so these are the these are the you know
the experts who are studying space-time
and they're the ones that are
pronouncing it's death
um and therefore the death of objects
inside space-time and the work that I've
been doing just agrees it says that
evolution of natural selection agrees
with the physicist at space-time even
though it's tacitly assumed in the way
that you know Darwin even thought about
Evolution when you look at the
mathematics of evolutionary theory it it
agrees that um that tacit assumption
um is false and that the theory of
evolution tells us that space and time
are not fundamental they're more like a
headset a virtual reality headset that
lets us play the game of life so when
evolution of a natural selection and
Quantum field Theory with Einstein's
gravity both tell us
that space and time and objects in space
and time are not fundamental then
latitude is we should go with the best
science and that means that a theory of
Consciousness which tries to boot up
Consciousness from physical systems is
doomed to fail it's doomed to fail
because our best science tells us that
space-time itself is doomed so we cannot
hope that it would be for example like
someone trying to to build a space
program
um on the assumption that the Earth is
flat uh well as soon as you find out the
Earth is not flat you you need new
assumptions to to to build your space
program that's just not the way you want
to to go so it was so my colleagues and
friends who are working on this it was a
wonderful assumption it was reasonable
to start with with neurons for example
or artificial intelligence circuits and
so forth
before we discovered that space-time is
not fundamental now that we know space
time is not fundamental
um
we're wasting our time well it's not a
complete waste of time because you'll
learn a lot even by you know starting
off with mistaken Foundation but
ultimately you won't you won't succeed
you will not be able to start with flat
Earth or space and time and boot up a
theory of Consciousness so so my
attitude is we need to to rethink from
the ground up of course I'm all for
Neuroscience I'm a cognitive
neuroscientist myself so I'm not saying
that brains are irrelevant we need to
study neural activity and we need to
study artificial intelligences but but
we have to study them in a very very
different way
um Evolution tells us that what we're
seeing is just an interface it's
it's there to guide adaptive Behavior
period
not to tell us the truth so when we look
inside brains and we see neurons in
neural circuits
we're seeing something that's very
important for us to understand but it's
just an interface it's not
it's an interface description it's not
the truth so
so we we so Neuroscience is going to be
far more difficult than than we thought
we're going to need more money for
Neuroscience because we look through
microscopes and we see neurons and
synapses and so forth and networks and
we thought that that's all we had to
deal with no that's just the surface of
what we have to deal with the reality
behind that is also something we're
going to have to deal with we'll have to
reverse engineer neurons and neural
networks and so forth so so so the short
answer is we we I don't think we can
start with any objects inside space and
time and boot up consciousness
although the only Clues we have are
inside space and time and so we have to
study for example cognitive Neuroscience
but we have to reverse engineer it and
find structures beyond space and time
that would allow us to boot up a theory
of Consciousness so you can see
um the game just got a lot harder and
far more interesting so long answer to
your question
sure
what's the difference between reality
and fundamentality
well so
I think the physicists would say that
um for example space-time is not
fundamental because it has no
operational meaning
below What's called the Planck scale 10
to the minus 33 centimeters 10 to the
minus 43 seconds
so so that that means that it's not for
a scientist it's not a deep enough
framework for us to build our theories
on
now so that that by itself would
preclude it being a fundamental reality
right so you know we're of course in the
hunt for reality in some sense
um in in science uh
but
each scientific theory
can only make certain assumptions it has
to start with certain assumptions and
then try to explain what it can based on
those assumptions so the assumption that
space and time and objects in space and
time is fundamental
um turns out not to be a good set of
assumptions and and therefore not a
candidate for the objective reality now
it could be
um reality quote unquote in some lesser
sense in the sense that it could be
um we have a real experiential
perception of space and time and a real
experiential perception of objects in
space and time so they could be real as
our particular experiences as our
particular interface but they're not
real in a more fundamental sense as
being
um so so I'll use the word real in two
different senses and I think that it's
important to distinguish them
one sense of real is something is real
if it exists and has all of its
properties even if it's never observed
so something is real and that I'll call
that an objective sense if it exists
with its properties even when it's not
observed
and so space time is not objective in
that sense we thought it was but it's
not
but there's another sense of real
and that is I I might say look I've got
a headache
and
um that headache only exists because I
perceive it it wouldn't exist if I
didn't perceive it but if you want to
tell me it's not real I would be very
cross with you because it's a it's a
painful headache so so you can see
there's another sense of real where
you'd say something is real if it's a
real experience even if that experience
uh only exists as long as it's being
experienced by by someone so there's two
senses of real real in the objective
sense and real in this subjective sense
and of course scientists have been
trying to find a reality in an objective
sense
um and so space time is not objective
reality
um and Evolution suggests that it's just
a subjective experience and and not
objective reality
now does all emergent SpaceTime theories
suggest that space-time is not objective
um because it's a different claim to
State subjective versus it's not
fundamental
sorry it's not objective versus not
right so so for physicists when they say
the space time is doomed they're saying
it's not fundamental
and uh
yeah I don't know what what they what
they would say about this objective
versus subjective kind of thing so I
don't know what the physicists would say
about that might you know they might say
well let me think about that uh you know
for us it's just not fundamental and you
know so for us it's not it's not real in
the sense that we need you know for our
theories of reality and and they they
may not be terribly interested in the
subject versus objective distinction for
for us in the cognitive neurosciences
it's a pretty important distinction to
make because we study subjective
experience as well as what we think
might be objective realities so so yeah
I don't know what the physicist would
say about about that
sure what is it about the amplitohedron
that attracts you to it more so than so
let's say some other approaches to
emerge of space-time or quantum gravity
right so
so the amplitude Hedon is is a structure
that nimora County Ahmed your house love
trinka and others have been working on
but uh trinka and and Nemo yorslautern
and Neymar were the ones who published
the paper I think in 2014. so this is
only less than 10 years old uh the this
this this discovery it's it's a
structure entirely outside of space-time
and entirely prior to quantum theory so
it's it's it's outside of both space
time and quantum theory and they argue
that space-time and quantum theory
um will emerge together from these
deeper structures like the amplitohedron
and and the reason I I think that I
prove really like their approach opposed
to some others is that they
they really
jump with both feet beyond space and
time it's it's you can't you can't go
halfway on this it's not just that space
is not fundamental it's also that time
is not fundamental and really that
quantum theory is not fundamental and so
so attempts to to try to go halfway
where you say well let's let's make time
fundamental or let's make particles
fundamental and we'll use uh you know
some kind of entanglement to try to boot
up a structure of space from particles
those just
are not serious enough you really have
to jump entirely outside of space and
time and particles and the reason why
you have to let go of the particles and
you can't just boot up space time from
entanglement of particles is that
Elementary particles the you know the
the bosons leptons and quarks are the
standard theory of
of particle physics
those what are those particles they're
what they call irreducible
representations of the poincare group
which is the group of symmetries of
space-time in other words the elementary
particles just are symmetries of
space-time so if you're trying to get a
new fundamental basis for booting up
space-time it's not particles because
those particles are defined in terms of
symmetries of space-time itself so so
what I like about the amplitohedron and
and the deeper structure so beyond the
amplitahedron they found these things
called decorated permutations but that's
sort of the deepest and biggest
most surprising structure they found and
these structures
um what what I like about them is they
go entirely beyond space and time and
the elementary particles which is the
kind of bold leap we need for our next
step halfway won't work it's just like
you you just have to go all the way or
if you don't swim out into the ocean if
you just stay on the shore you'll never
get there you've got to jump away from
the shore and really go out there beyond
space and time
where do the fitness functions come from
so that requires me to say a little bit
about our approach um which is about
Consciousness being fundamental right so
great so the physicists so I should say
you know what we're doing and what the
physicists of then how it's related
what's beyond space-time so the
physicists
are looking for mathematical structures
Beyond space-time that would allow them
to do things like compute the
probabilities of particle interactions
at colliders like the Large Hadron
Collider so you want something that's
going to be mathematically precise and
rigors outside of space and time that
allows you to boot up the structures of
space and time you know lorentz
invariants and things like that
um or quantum gravity
and they you also want to be able to
compute fundamental things like
so-called scattering amplitudes the
probability that two gluons smash into
each other and four gluons spray out in
a certain way
so so they're finding structures like
the amplitohedron and decorative
permutations which let them do that but
they have no Dynamics beyond space time
these are static structures Beyond
space-time
and physics
typically likes to find some kind of
dynamical theory
and so what I'm doing with with my
collaborators
um caitan prakash from new Singh and and
Robert prentner and and many others uh
is we're we've got a mathematical model
of consciousness
um being fundamental and Beyond
space-time
and why we do that we can we can go into
that later on if you want why we start
there but but the idea is that
Consciousness is fundamental and and
it's a dynamical system of Consciousness
it's like a social network an
interacting network uh like the
twitterverse where there's lots of you
know agents that are
um communicating with other agents
tweeting and following and the whole bit
that's sort of a good intuitive model of
it
and our paper that was just published
today fusions of Consciousness goes into
the mathematics so people can who are
interested you know there's a paper
that's they just Google fusions of
Consciousness in my name you can see the
paper they just came out today that goes
into this into the mathematics but so we
have this mathematical model of
Consciousness in which Consciousness is
fundamental and our goal is to show that
space and time
are not fundamental as the physicists
say and that they arise as merely a user
interface that conscious agents some
conscious agents use space and time as a
a way to um to facilitate their
interactions with other conscious agents
so they space and time was just a user
interface so for us to do that we have
to show how precisely space and time and
the standard model of physics and so
forth
um arise
um from a dynamics of conscious agents
right so we have we have a lot of work
to do we have to say okay here's our
mathematical model of Consciousness it's
not just a hand wave we're not saying
wouldn't it be nice if Consciousness is
fundamental we're saying here's our
precise mathematical model of
Consciousness and now we have to say
here's precisely
how we compute scattering amplitudes in
space-time based on our model because we
now have this mapping from a conscious
agent Dynamics into space-time so that's
what this paper fusions of Consciousness
is setting up to do is to is
mapping from dynamics of Consciousness
into space-time and the fun part of it
is
what we decided to do was hey the
physicists have already gone outside of
space-time they found these deep
structures like decorated permutations
Beyond space-time so what we need to do
because what they've shown is if you can
give us decorative permutations we can
take you all the way back into space
time and we can compute scattering
amplitudes so we said okay great you've
already done
most of the heavy lifting all we need to
do is take our Theory Of Consciousness
and show how decorated permutations are
a simple model or a simple projection of
our theory of consultations so that's
what this paper does what we we actually
set out to do that and we did it we
showed how to take our markovian
dynamics of conscious agents project it
into decorative permutations and by the
way that was apparently that was a new
mathematical contribution
um we were the first as far as I know to
have a general theory of how you take a
Markov chain and canonically associate
with it a decorated permutation so
having done that
um we then um have this mapping in
principle all the way from a theory of
conscious agents through decorative
permutations through all the structures
that the physicists have found in the
space-time so so so now what we're so
one one thing we learned from doing that
is we now know what feature of our
markovian Dynamics
is critical to this to the connection
with with particle physics
foreign